what's up everybody welcome to culture
binge we're Rafi ston everything going
on in the zeitgeist and digest it for
all of you our beautiful listeners this
is the episode for the week of July 15
2019
I'm your host Jared and with me today
are my amazing co-hosts Alec hey I am in
LA and surbhi hi I am NOT in LA so he's
not in LA she's actually at a conference
for work so she's joining us from
Portland hello so right up top want to
remind everybody that culture binge is
now on Apple podcast stitcher SoundCloud
Google podcasts etc so please subscribe
there if you're listening to us on
YouTube right now and leave a review
we've actually got Alec once to give a
couple shout outs to people who've been
kind enough to leave us a review
I have many shout outs tie-dye afropunk
Technologist black as coal black as coal
says what a way to capture the zeitgeist
with my virtual friends you're as
virtual friend I guess so am i Lucy Zak
half co-op who says the only thing
wisecrack does poorly is self-promotion
because this has been out for two months
and I had no idea thank you to all of
you we've actually hasn't been out for
two months we've been doing it for two
months but we only put creative the RSS
feed last which you could consider bad
promotion but I do want to say first of
all please leave us a review because it
helps other people find the podcast so
we can keep making the podcast but also
I want to encourage you to leave
somewhat ridiculous review so I can
really read them on air nothing negative
nothing you know like Jared murdered my
parents please please don't do that we
don't need that on the internet but
anything else how's it have been funny
if you like the podcast please do
definitely if you want sir be to start
doing mukbang let that voice be heard on
our iTunes reviews yeah also just before
we get jared show off your wonderful
shirt oh yeah so a couple weeks ago Alec
bought me a shirt just yeah I mean you
get it it's like instead of instead of
wolves howling out the moon it's
Dziedzic howling at the moon and we were
at a joke on where a bunch of educators
were and nobody record educators YouTube
educators and nobody recognized except
Phillip the guy who runs Kurt skits acht
aka in a nutshell so further solidifying
that he is the king of YouTube yeah he's
the greatest
yeah Thank You Philip for being the only
one out of a roomful of educators that
got the shirt or who knew who this was
they're all scientists they are all
scientists great people though but as
always we are going to go around and say
what's slapping and what's chapping this
week let's start with Alec now let's
start with Serbia okay disappointed
about that Jared yeah
so my slap is I am very disappointed
with a big little lies the second season
it's not good I feel like it's just very
disappointing I was super excited about
it a few weeks ago but what oh wait that
was my chap
so my slap here is um I just discovered
Jane the Virgin and like I thought it
was like a silly kind of a show it's
about it's sort of like a teen ish show
I think is on this it was about a girl
who said that she wouldn't remain a
virgin until marriage and then she ended
up becoming artificially inseminated by
mistake and it's a story about that so I
thought it was just kind of lame and
then I started watching it it's actually
quite funny so that's very I'm very
happy making I heard there was some sort
of creative control was taken away from
the showrunner on big little lies or
something like that going on is that why
it's bad I think that's part of it like
the scenes don't feel like they flow
very well like it seems a little bit
choppy but also I feel like they rely
too heavily on flashbacks so I'm not
sure if that's part of the creative
control but they flashback to the first
season a bit too much and there's like
this weird like mystical element where
one of the characters has visions and
any time like something is just randomly
inserted like that where there's like
visions or somebody's like like a
psychic or something like I immediately
get turned off mm-hmm it's not like a
fantasy or something before I get into
mind we've already got some donations
and I want to thank those people by
probably for any other I don't want to
the live stream too much so I might save
them all for thanking you all at the end
but before that dude abides thank you
for your donation and I'm going to
mispronounce this a new food and life I
don't know
he comment complimented our interstellar
video I guess he or she so thank you for
those donations however my I who wrote
that Tommy cook he's currently writing
on the new charmed show on an NBC or CBS
shout out the Tommy shallows Tommy who
by the way he started writing on that
show but he had never seen the episode
of charmed until a week before he was
hired and so he had to binge every
episode of the old charmed before he
started writing the new char are you
gonna get him in trouble for this
no I don't know nobody tell Tommy's boss
okay so my slaps is edge you can't slash
VidCon specifically the people there we
met a lot of really awesome creators
just people in the space I had a really
great time even though there's certain
problems with VidCon that I hate which
gets me to my chaps which is also the
people at VidCon because besides those
people it's just full of children who
are being sucked into the attention
economy and I don't blame the children
necessarily but for instance there's a
great moment where I was at a party and
there were some teens and they were
dancing nothing wrong with dancing but I
noticed they were looking around while
they were dancing and they were dancing
very well and very showily
they were looking around noticed nobody
was watching them and then immediately
stopped and they did that three or four
times and I was just sitting in a corner
wondering what you were watching right
well they didn't see me I was trying to
be stealthily stealthy and creepy about
it but also just you know you go on the
showroom floor and it's all just selling
13-year olds that they need to be
youtubes start and I obviously love
YouTube and but I feel like there's a
difference between I want to communicate
science or philosophy or I want to be a
storyteller and this is where the
audiences versus I want to be famous
which gets me to just a quick little
article there's one of our patrons
sentence in our discord Ars Technica has
an article where American kids would
rather be youtubers than astronauts this
is according to a poll of I believe 3000
kids done by commissioned by Lego
and can you Mitch put that up nope not
that that's aliens we're getting to
aliens
so China they still want to be
astronauts as trying to gone to the moon
yet or the point is UK similar problem
United States terrible ah that makes me
sad and that chaps my ass okay but a
couple things as far as China doesn't
have YouTube they have some sort of
equivalent I don't really know if it's
monetized as much as YouTube is though
yeah so I don't know if it really is as
much of a career path although if
somebody lives in China or as lived in
China knows definitely write us in an
email culture binge or wisecrack duh co
but I don't think this is anything new
when I was a kid everybody wanted to be
a movie star rather than an astronaut or
a doctor what's the difference I feel
like the standard for kids is I want to
be a firefighter an astronaut sometimes
the police officer and a doctor maybe
and then then then there's the kids who
say they want to be famous and those
kids are the probably sign so young are
these kids you don't really need to
start taking any career path seriously
until your early-to-mid high school if
even that oh I mean I'm sure 50% is
Chinese kids who want to be astronauts
not 50% will be I just think it's a
cultural snapshot that horrifies me yeah
but I would say that the Chinese are
probably they're probably taught that
they're just taught about the necessity
of having a practical job more than
Americans at least at a young age I
would guess I mean being a youtuber is
practical if you're making money maybe a
more utilitarian job is that the better
yeah public good yeah it creates social
value I guess youtubers do too I love
YouTube thanks you too sorry survey you
can hear the algorithm favoring us as
Alex's I think I think it is a bit
cultural and that maybe certain
countries don't favor professions that
garner quite a bit of attention so
something like YouTube might feel a bit
too self-absorbed for some cultures
which is why it's not a popular
profession
and it's very chaotic if you studied to
be a doctor there's a really good chance
you can get a high-paying job as a
doctor if you pursue YouTube there's a
very low chance that you're gonna get a
high paying job as a youtuber that's
another thing that makes me sad it's one
thing if you know kids want to be me
well musicians are just as bad as far as
the ability to succeed as a musician but
yeah it's a pipe dream it's just we in
America wait until later to crush
people's dreams and it's part of because
we don't want to crush people's
creativity yeah in China I studied
abroad in China for like four months I
took two years of Chinese language I
don't remember any of it
but I was pretty good at a time yes I
know what that means but yeah they're
education kids have homework and are
doing math problems and multiplication
tables in like kindergarten
whereas when we're in kindergarten it's
all about creativity it's all about just
playing and exploring and social skills
but for them creativity is not as
emphasized hmm so anyway for me what's
laps it's been a pretty simple week the
only thing that's really been slapping
in my life is that there's new chopped
episodes on Hulu you know it's the small
things it's the small things as far as
chaps similarly there's no good video
games coming out it's been a slow summer
it's been a slow last month
you know what chaps is I actually got
suckered in to buying the new super
mario brothers you on the switch because
I never got a Wii U and I got sucked in
because I knew it was a game that was
basically a port but they said it was
two games in one but the two games in
one claim is basically [ __ ] cuz it's
just one game with a hard mode so I feel
like I paid full price for something
that wasn't entirely worth it but it's
still a good game but yeah that's what
chaps me no new exciting video games
really coming out until I guess next
week the new fire emblem comes out but
anyway that's it but before we get into
the main segments today Alec has a new
segment that he would like to introduce
tell us about it Alec well I don't
really know the name I guess I should
have thought of this earlier adventures
in advertising adventures in late
capitalism I don't know but there is
that Rita is a brand you may not
recognize that name but you do probably
recognize Budweiser's Lima Rita's straw
just the margarita esque flavored things
in cans although I'm told by our in
parents that they don't taste like
margaritas so here's a tweet from the
Rita's brand well it will read that if
we put it on-screen
Thank You Mitch
we have something to say and then
there's old down pointing arrow hashtag
never apologize and is that the note
happened in iPhones yeah yeah so the
note app hey ladies trashy period gross
I'm gonna go I can say the period so let
me do that again
Hey ladies trashy gross girly basic
sweet we've we've been called it all on
Twitter urban dictionary everywhere and
we get it we're a margarita in a can but
we can't help but notice these labels
are also used to bring down women and
that we don't get it ladies it's time to
take their labels cover them in glitter
and make them our own together to all of
us who dress and do as we please to all
of us busy taking selfies while they
call us basic to all those who know
trashy is just another word for fun
we'll never be sorry for who we are
no one should now first of all I want to
say it's not this well let's just let's
just put up the best reply that I ll
that this is top of mind Twitter this is
from at showing the dogs that should be
one of our podcasts I mean my Twitter
let me make it very clear I buy your
product because it tastes like candy and
has 8% alcohol content that's it it's
not because you're being fake woke on
Twitter yes sir B what's your take
I'm actually not offended but I am
feeling very negative about this Oh God
about the ad about that note I think
it's it
I don't need your disingenuous words to
try to like draw parallels between your
[ __ ] brand and what women are like what
they experience like stop trying to like
tell us to like reclaim labels and stuff
like that I feel like it
trivializes what people actually go
through yeah because I think at the
surface it's things like you know
certain expectations are placed on women
that you maybe don't want to do and you
shouldn't apologize for them but that is
different than getting shit-faced on a
lie Marita walking to McDonald's and
then swearing at the person because they
messed up your order or it's not coming
out fast enough and saying hashtag never
apologize these are two different things
and I think clearly the social media
manager at the ritas doesn't understand
that and I think in general corporations
don't understand that or maybe you're
the dumbass and they do understand it in
the fact that we're talking about it
right now have probably just introduced
our audience or at least me who I didn't
even know Rita's was a brand but you've
now now I know you've seen the lie
Marita fine but I still have increased
awareness before this tweet and after
this tweet I will also say I love malt
liquor and I will never apologize but it
doesn't need to be a whole social
awareness campaign
yeah just any any claim to liberation
it seems that companies will now try to
co-op to sell their brand it's like you
know it every I once saw a don't stop
smoking commercial which had a bunch of
people coming out as gay or bi or
something like that and then it's a hard
right turn to don't smoke and like what
are the two have to do with each other
and with this it's like okay so you know
we've already said that you know you can
express yourself your sexuality or
gender or whatever and now it's just you
can be as trashy as you want or as
belligerent as you want and you
shouldn't apologize for that
basically just there's don't have shame
for anything that you're exactly perfect
how you are by our brand there's a
there's a video ad it's essentially the
same thing hashtag never apologize it's
on their Twitter if anyone wants check
it out
can someone please recut it with the
footage of the guy screaming pickle Rick
on top of McDonald's counter that guy
wasn't drunk though I know but I mean he
might as well have been he was drunk on
the power of Szechuan so that guy was I
I've also heard that that guy was joking
he was doing it for a joke that
particular example but there were people
being shitty event I mean if you're joke
being shitty by jumping up on a count
are you just being regular shitty I
don't know maybe maybe before the
cameras are rolling he's like hey I'm
gonna just do this thing for his viral
I'll clean the table afterwards you know
don't worry just plug your ears for
about five minutes maybe you did that I
don't know yeah well anyway I'll
encourage people what is a culture binge
at watch crack Co yep
send us your adventures in advertising
or suggest a better name than that any
anything if you've been listening you
know the subway ad you know this you
know the the sad meals anything in that
vein just please send it I want to talk
about it I mean I don't envy people who
are social media managers or in the
marketing department of these brands
because if your job is to you know up
brand awareness by ten percent how do
you do that except by either a doing
something that's as dumb is what we just
did in order to increase brand awareness
which we have helped to do or be just
how do you do it without just creating
something outrageous right Wendy's has a
fantastic social media manager I love I
don't think they're there anymore
they're still not well I don't know hey
this was a year or two you're talking my
how they roast people right yeah maybe
they still do who knows
but it's great sorry sorry to interrupt
you if anybody's listening and wants to
see how a brand does social right you
should check out the Wendy's Twitter all
right all right let's go into the main
story so sir be starting us off with a
story about jewel yes
so recently the Food and Drug
Administration declared teen vaping and
epidemic stating that nearly 21 percent
of high school students vaped last year
a former FDA Commissioner blamed this
teen vaping epidemic on Joule which is
an e-cigarette company and when asked
what he would say to a parent whose
child is addicted to Joule the CEO Kevin
Burns said first of all I tell them that
I'm sorry that their child's using the
project product it's not intended for
them I hope there was nothing that we
did that made it appealing to them as a
parent of a 16 year old I'm sorry for
them I have
for them in terms of the challenges that
they're going through so those are very
very lovely words but Jules critics
point to the company's initial
advertising campaign which featured
bright colors young models and they say
that these advertisements encouraged
teens to vape because it looked cool and
exciting and the co-founder of Joule
Adam Bowen said in retrospect that the
ads were inappropriate so the company
has tried to combat teen vaping by
shutting down its social media accounts
and pulling fruity flavors like cream
and mango from retailers so I was very
conflicted when I read that the CEO
apologized for this one I think it's
hypocritical that he says he hopes that
there was nothing that they did to
encourage teen vaping clearly I know
they knew and also I'm just so shocked
that teens are vaping considering the
amount of research about the adverse
effects of nicotine and while we don't
know the long-term effects of vaping I
think the average reasonable person
would assume that there are some
negative effects I and well sorry as
someone I mean I am familiar with the
science that smoking is terrible for you
but I have a friend who is an adult but
was switching to vaping and I don't know
if this is PR if this is true if is
assuming it's false they're like no no
because it's not smoke because it's
vapor it is not bad for you and all the
way cigarettes are there and he would
say there's no studies that vaping is
bad for you now I take that with a huge
grain of salt but go ahead yeah there's
probably no studies that vaping is good
for you either and we don't have any
studies that show what is the effect on
one's lungs throat tongue so I I think
there are two sides to this story that
are baffling one that teens are vaping
knowing the risks and the second is that
an organization I mean I know that a lot
of companies are hypocritical I know
that they're doing this but when it
comes to tobacco companies
and anybody who sells nicotine products
I always give them a heavy dose of side
I in a former role I spoke with a an
executive at a tobacco organization and
they this these people were cold blooded
I mean they knew exactly what they were
doing they know they know that they're
targeting young people they know and so
when I was having this conversation with
them they basically had no remorse I
mean they said well it's not up to us we
can sell a product and if people want to
buy it they can they can buy it and
that's their choice which is true
however I think it's just absurd that
Jule now says oh I hope that we didn't
do anything okay okay more to what
you're saying about how ruthless they
are how cynical do you think this gets
because part of me thinks that the
apology was part of part of the plan in
that all right we have a five-year plan
for two years we mark it mercilessly to
teens then eventually it hits some sort
of inflection point where people start
getting mad about it
then we apologize and essentially cash
out and then they've already reached a
bar they've already got them and they're
already hooked and those original teens
are now adults and they're fine and now
yeah so I've heard this phrase over and
over again and I'm convinced almost
anyone who says this is a sociopath but
I hear it a lot from important business
people the phrase it is better to ask
for forgiveness than to ask for
permission I've heard it so many times
in the business world in different
contexts but I am nearly positive in my
head my head Canon that at some point
someone in some meeting said hey do you
think this is a marketing to kids and
the response was it's better to ask
forgiveness and ask permission because
oftentimes whether it's uber you know
exploiting their drivers or Amazon
mistreating their warehouse they always
say what is the profitable thing to do
will people get angry well we'll ask for
like it is part of the business model to
ask forgiveness so I don't buy yeah I
don't buy it at all or like I buy it as
part of the strategy kind of Jarrod's
point I agree I think that this is
probably well rehearsed beforehand
and
is part of a long-term plan especially
since this exact same thing happened
with actual cigarettes so they're just
like [ __ ] it we'll do it again yeah cuz
all those people are dead they can't
probably remember what we did back in
the day
I mean apologies in general I think in
the public setting are mostly [ __ ]
yeah there's that South Park with BP
we're sorry I'm sorry you should have
that club there I mean I think in the
I've never had a marketing job but
running a YouTube channel in which you
know we make all of our money from
advertising the only way we were able to
stay alive is advertising I have met
with other marketing teams and in a
couple situations I'm not going to name
people it seemed I was like the one
raising their hand and saying okay so
for example there was a brand that was a
cereal brand that was looking to make a
big spend on YouTube and this particular
cereal was one of the cereals that had a
ton of sugar in it and the the ad rep
who is somebody that I was relatively
familiar with I know that they had just
had a kid and they said so this brand
wants to put on a ad campaign that
promotes the cereal as healthy yeah and
they want to use the healthy terminology
healthy this healthy that and I just
said and and there was like probably six
or seven people in this room and I just
had to raise my hand and say right but
it's not like you just had a kid you're
telling me that you would feed this to
your kid I was in I was in one of these
meetings now so I think there were
euphemisms it might have not even been a
healthy have been like part of a healthy
diet in the way that yeah I guess if
you're having a candy bar once a week
you could still have a healthy diet but
so they're either making the false claim
or just making extremely misleading
claims and this person just basically
recovered with a bunch of business speak
that softened the claim but still was
asserting the claim and they basically
just said okay I guess wisecracks is not
the right brand for this yeah man we
have so many interesting meetings about
about and with advertisers yeah
aren't anything else you want to add sir
be oh no I'm gay that was great
all right we're gonna talk about the
area 51 Facebook group I'm sure that
everyone listening has heard about this
because it's so big but last month a
Facebook group was created called storm
area 51 they can't stop all of us it's
description red we will all meet up at
the area 51 alien center tourist
attraction and coordinate our entry if
we Naruto run we can move faster than
their bullets
let's see them aliens not sure and at
the time of this recording the number of
attendees scheduled to appear at this
event is nearing 1.5 million it's
actually I only checked this morning it
probably surpassed 1.5 million seemingly
every news publication has covered this
Facebook page
the event creators maintain that the
whole thing is a joke meant to establish
a new forum for alien UFO and conspiracy
theory memes rather than a genuine
effort to break into a heavily guarded
military base and it certainly has
generated a lot of memes it seems like
at least 5 means 5 memes are uploaded to
the page every minute so I want to
highlight some of the my favorite memes
that I found yesterday morning so here's
one where we see Elliot please Elliot
from et and ETS in the basket with a
blanket around with a blanket around it
and it over the over the alien it's
alien I took from area 51 and the guys
pursuing Elliot are 250,000 Naruto
runners covering me let's see this next
one this one is a is a shot from the
final battle of endgame and Wars what
you thought you were gonna go into
endgame and there wasn't gonna be a
final battle man okay so Thanos is the
area 51 guards and the people that are
fighting Thanos are furries redditors
roblox players minecraft players 9 year
olds literally everyone Facebook users
fortnight players let's do one more
really interesting you should bring that
in next week this one is a image of the
second Harry Potter movie with Ron
Weasley in his car and he's an area 51
guard looking very distressed as he sees
behind him the first wave of Chi
for Kyle's I was gonna ask you that I
feel like I'm the intern expert here and
I feel yeah I feel like Kyle's are I'm
gonna guess oh there's another good one
here's the storm fairy a storm area51
vehicle fleet they got the heat truck
the Subaru which will distract guards
with to step back fire and conclude your
vape clouds which will perfectly cover
the Naruto runners they got a Volvo tank
which were hipsters will use them to
sweep hidden mines and then finally we
have the Mustang kamikaze pilots so this
is hilarious to me 400 is so seemingly
so alec is gonna talk about little na
sex a little bit later but seemingly
overnight lil no sex has released
another remix of Old Town Road on
YouTube this time with an animated video
portraying the supposed read including
Naruto runners with Keanu Reeves heads
storming the site as well as an alien
giving young thug a new chain by the way
this new remix has young thug in it + so
for those of you watching the live
stream you can see there's an animation
the security booth at area 51 there's an
alien flag and then what's the other the
the yodeling kid from yeah what's his
Mesa
I gotta written somewhere Mason Ramsey
this whole thing is the most meme
postmodern thing ever because the whole
thing even we already showed there was
Thanos on a bird head there was the
Infinity Gauntlet there's all these
matrix things in the background the
Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves is on an R 2
runners head for no other reason than
the fact that Keanu Reeves was big on
the internet recently this space this
video is just a big hodgepodge of
internet meme stuff is this Anthony fan
tanto from the needle drop I think so I
don't really know but I think I saw that
name it looks exactly like him yeah
that's pretty awesome if it is him so
yeah and then in this video the military
is basically trying to stop the waves of
Keanu Reeves Naruto runners as well as
young thug getting a new chain so this
event the event creators are now selling
t-shirts with slogans on them like I saw
them aliens I survived area 51 and I
clap alien cheeks
so let me tell you what this is
hilarious oh here are some of the shirts
there's also one that says I [ __ ] love
aliens I wonder how many of these are
actually being sold because also on the
page this is the official page selling
the t-shirts but everyone's got their
own t-shirt that they're trying to sell
because they know that there's a lot of
traffic going to this webpage what are
we why don't we make an Etsy store right
now and just start selling I bet you
they're not selling well there's just
too much competition I feel like the
2,000 people watching this right now
I've would would buy one of our shirts
oh and we should also sell that Dziedzic
shirt yeah from China
what is buy from China and resale for
double its capitalism
alright so I've got some thoughts as to
why this is funny
it's amazing by the way this is actually
my favorite thing that's happened on the
internet in awhile but so last week we
were talking about how Google censorship
we're talking about Google censorship or
YouTube spent censorship and I believe
it was you Alec you mentioned that you
understand that Google doesn't want to
be in the business of determining
whether or not something is a joke yeah
and what I love about this is that it's
forcing the US military to do just that
to see if they can recognize where a
joke starts and where the serious crazy
people ends and I think that whenever
you're bringing a you know quote-unquote
very serious straight-faced
institution that is you know elevates
itself above the inane crazy nihilistic
internet culture and subjecting them to
your sense of humor it's very satisfying
yeah well the Army's response was this
is a terrible idea we will shoot you
yeah and I feel like they don't actually
have to determine cuz they'll determine
when they see if people are running
towards the area 51 in which case they
will shoot because the minute they start
to do it it is no longer a joke how many
people do you think are actually gonna
show up
no maybe yeah I think oh but that's just
like there's always maybe like someone
well yeah especially maybe unwell people
who don't fully understand it's really
see I don't I don't think that's gonna
be the case I think that there are gonna
be some ironic internet people who are
just going to go regularly like they're
just gonna go and see the tourist
attraction like any other patron but
because this event has some so
of legendary status they'll just want to
be able to say I went on September 20th
2019 do you think like the person you
know that went to Joshua Tree for the
profile picture they'll get a flight to
area 51 they'll pose they'll pose for
doing that the run pose and then
immediately leave no I don't think that
person is that person's born to like The
Bachelor and but not into like 4chan
deep no I'm saying other people are
gonna fly there to take the profile
picture of them do the new route the run
I don't know if they need to do that on
that exact date and increase their
chances of being shot but I think people
are going to be doing that but maybe not
there's a good chance that by September
19th all this could be blown over and
everyone's forgotten I've forgotten
about it and it's old news
yeah so I also think that there's a
sense of collective accomplishment for
Internet people
enforcing government institutions and
the news media to recognize the kind of
nihilistic despair that these memes
operate on because I think one of the
very essential things as to why this is
funny is because it's a suicide mission
right and then the joke is are we really
joking or are we that depressed yeah can
you put up Mitch can you put up one of
the memes the depressed area 51 memes
that's its own folder yeah this is one
The Cat in the Hat is coming behind a
kid with a baseball bat and the kid has
text over him saying area 51 thinking
this is a joke and the Cat in the Hat
has text over him saying Millennials
engines and Gen Z's willingness to die
so this made me oh here's another one
this is a meme somebody posted it's just
text over black that says area 51 will
either be the most successful government
takeover of all time or the biggest
[ __ ] graveyard home to the bravest
Americans with the IQ of a straw either
way the memes will be fire yeah so fire
emoji fire armor this made me just to
think more about just [ __ ] posting in
general yeah and just so what is
shitposting I think the best definition
from urban dictionary I was able to find
is it's an ironic art form of expressive
yet apathetic fun posting and then
there's an article in surface magazine
by Gustavo Turner who adds this
definition by saying that there used to
confuse derail meaning and entertain
there's another great quote from Turner
he says what is a shitpost if not a
pointless carnivalesque attack against
meaning itself like every aesthetic that
draws from the absurd like dadaism
surrealism situationism Punk shitposting
is ultimately a cry of despair against
impending disaster this reminds me of
I've never I've always convinced
considered him as the most wholesome
troll on the internet but Ken M if
there's any fans listening do you know
who can a mezzo
he will just usually troll brands on
Facebook with it's like a very confused
boomer on the Internet is this persona
and ask questions like my oven won't
turn on GE can you help me but as oven
is full of magazines and they'll say you
shouldn't do that fire has in there but
fine I took them out and they're like
over an open flame and just other very
dumb gray just there's a can I'm
separate it can explain I'm not fully
prepared to discuss cannon but I think
to your point about nihilism there is
something interesting there yeah it's a
kind of bizarre free therapy for
Millennials and Gen Z errs and I also
think there's an element of it being a
reaction against a world where seemingly
all content is sponsored content and
shitposting memes are deliberately non
monetizable they can't be co-opted by
Rita's or by any kind of corporate
sponsor well no but they well they sort
of can so this is the whole thing with
brand twitter ria propria lee nihilist
for a while or even Sunny D being like
I'm not okay I guess they're right yeah
there's an interesting so when we made
we made a video about the Bert's at
Burger King commercial and then all the
comments were why aren't you talking
about Sarah Z's video on fast-food
advertising which really dives into this
and a different but similar way that we
did that there's a very interesting and
sort of not completionist history but
something like that but yeah I think
they can take advantage of it yeah maybe
you're right but I mean there is
something that at least a meme itself is
so ugly so negative that you're never
gonna see a corporation call up a guy
who created a simple meme like one of
the ones we just said and say hey we
love your work let's sponsor it
hopefully do it
well they'll steal the idea yeah yes
it also similarly it's not quite brands
but reddit is always complaining that
Instagram normies are stealing their
memes so in the meme subreddits there
are always the joke is literally just
defacing a meme so that reddit Kansas so
that Instagram can't steal it by either
putting a watermark or some memes are
only visible in dark mode on or night
mode on reddit which Instagram doesn't
have that functionality yeah I guess the
question that I want to ask is why is
depression a part of the cult the
counterculture now surbhi what do you
think I think they this reminds me of
some of the stuff in high school where
it would be like the depressed emo kids
would even your hell growing up and
children I think more than its they sort
of see it as like a badge of honor
or something that's like cool and trendy
and it gives them I don't know
makes them distinct in some way I don't
know the whole thing is baffling and I'm
just jealous of people who have [ __ ]
posts that get really big because I want
a [ __ ] post you can yes sir I'm gonna
[ __ ] pose you can am slash mukbang it'll
be a very specific brand for you you two
are talking to like the next big
Internet star I hope you're prepared
we're very prepared so one of our
patrons on our discord sent us a link
about eagerly girls are this kind of
wraps into this whole discussion yeah
they're ironic too it's it's an
electronic girl not emo girl but they
kind of seem emo yeah they'll often have
like a teardrop tattoo or drawing under
their eye they kind of look like scene
girls yeah just to give everyone the
basic definition of a god yeah so the
urban dictionary definition is a Negros
a species of emo usually found on
tik-tok but commonly spends time on
tumblr can be found wearing pink
eyeshadow with a
Wiig heart little hearts under their
eyes and a blush nose normally wearing
some type of shirt from Urban Outfitters
or a long-sleeve striped shirt and these
girls or boys tend to romanticize and
joke about things such as anxiety and
depression making it seem cool to be
mentally ill and yeah I just I was like
is it is it that if you're not mentally
it has I used to think this I used to
think that if you weren't depressed it's
because a lack of awareness a lack of
awareness of how horrible the world is I
don't know if I still believe that but
do you think that that's why that's one
of the reasons why mental illnesses I
don't know if it's considered cool I
don't think anyone explicitly says like
oh man you listen to that person he's
mentally healthy what a [ __ ] tool
like I don't think it's quite like that
but I do think that there is a
romanticization of people dealing with
depression or mental illness I I was
watching this thing the other day that
uses the phrase the future is cancelled
which says that this is in the context
of how culture has their the idea was if
you go from the 50s to the if you drop
someone from 1950 into 1960s musically
what is this is completely new but if
you drop someone from 2010 to today they
would mostly understand the music that
was happening maybe not mumble rap but
the idea is that we're not really
culturally progressing because we're
just making lion-king remakes all day
now this is culturally but I also think
techno like think about on technological
level in the 60s we went to the moon
that's the 50th anniversary we just saw
that and now we can barely get into
space I mean I know we're sending up
satellites and doing all these things
but it just seems like technologically
economically scientifically we don't
have a whole lot going on so I don't
know if I agree with that you think that
so sorry you made the claim that
somebody from whatever the 90s if they
listened to today's music they'd kind of
get maybe not the 90s but the 2000s I
think even people today listen to young
thug for the first time and they're like
what is this I don't even know who young
thug is like I would be that person I
think that's not yeah I think you could
sir he's huge like he's a [ __ ] star I
think you can certainly find examples
and it's a claim I'm a little
I want to think critically of it but I
think overall just the idea that we are
not progressing anymore now we may be
progressing in some ways but I often
think the ways we're progressing is that
Facebook is making a ton of money and
that is a lot different than putting
people on the moon or going to Mars or
you know like Elon Musk gets all this
love for SpaceX but all he's doing is
essentially doing in a better way what
we try what we already accomplished in
the 60s well there's all those other
things like the underground bullet train
yeah yeah stuff like that well yeah he's
he's drilling a hole under the ground
for a car to go through like I'm
inventing the future hey man you haven't
driven in LA traffic I understand the
necessity for that [ __ ] I have been in
LA traffic and I understand the
necessity of a thing called subways
they're awesome and you have those yeah
and they suck they don't they don't
they're fine there's just it's just a
very spread out place yeah there's not
enough of them the point is that I think
this nihilism from shitposting and eager
all's comes from a fact that we're not a
very hopeful society anymore because
whether or not it's true we feel like
we're not progressing the futures
cancelled whatever and also at record
rates people are experiencing anxiety
depression so it's not that anxiety
depression are cool it's just that all
these kids are anxious and depressed and
therefore make like McCobb jokes about
it as you know I I make McCobb jokes all
the time not about those things but I
think that people do think that from my
experience what I've observed is said
when somebody deals with anxiety and
depression I think that it they sort of
have this air of well you don't know
what I go through you don't know my
struggles like I have anxiety I have
mental illness or I have trauma and who
doesn't have [ __ ] trauma like who
doesn't have had things that make them
sad or upset so I think that maybe there
are people who are normal rational
individuals who have mental illness like
anxiety and depression and they cope
with those in healthy ways and then I
think there are people who feed into the
label of having a mental illness and
those are the people that that look at
look at their
disorders as something that's cool or
sets them apart or gives them some sort
of like respect from others remember
last week when we were talking about
reality TV I think that you could even
draw some sort of similarity here
because whether it's reality TV or just
narrative movies there's always a
romantic element in which somebody is
portrayed as wow they overcame so much
or rather that their depression or the
stuff that they went through as a kid I
mean look at Batman his parents killed
the fact that his parents were killed
before his very eyes is basically his
superpower because he was able to
harness that depression and then become
a super myopic focused ninja yeah and so
I mean you know like I was saying last
week with reality TV everyone's got a
sob story people win the end it's always
brought back to oh the war has taken
such a horrible toll in my life but now
I'm a chopped champion so it's awesome
and so people when they look to wanting
to be a unique individual or wanting to
find meaning in life they look at these
people who have only been able to create
that meaning by going through some sort
of struggle or depression or something
severely [ __ ] up and that's not good
life is way simpler than that and it's
not I mean in some ways it's simpler
than that but you really don't need to
fetishize your suffering in order to
create meaning in life but it's so funny
I mean are funny with that man our
mutual favourite Instagram is an
animator who did one of our episodes
yeah we okay everyone follow at
imitation rice it's the best Instagram
on on Instagram and she does the best
[ __ ] posting memes and she also they're
always about depression anxiety and Star
Trek which are yeah but she did she
animated our video on Fahrenheit 451 our
pilot that took us six months last year
anyway yeah I think at the end of the
day everybody wants to be the hero of
their own story yeah exactly but your
life isn't a [ __ ] story no it's not
but people think that there's this like
invisible camera that's like hovering
over them like
Mario game like watching them and why is
that like is that has that always
existed or is that because of the
increase in social media and putting
your life on Instagram and Facebook and
things hmm depends on who you ask
we did like to McLuhan videos in the
last two months and he would say it all
started with the written word that
because when you're able to read a book
in solitude by yourself it creates a
mental space of individuality hmm and
it's probably only gotten worse and
worse with cinema TV internet etc anyway
let's move on so Alec wants to talk
about Nestle which is apparently
connected but I haven't heard about any
of this yeah so it's a very neat chiyan
turn if area 51 is incredibly nihilist
this is breaking through nihilism as
teacher might say to find some meaning
in something so people have piggybacked
off the area 51 meme too so let me
before we show it I'll just say that the
basic issue here is someone made a post
on reddit it was in meme format but not
about area 51 Nestle bottled water in
Southern California where it's very
prone to drought or they also bought a
water during drought but it's not just
their their bottled water in your Flint
where people I believe still don't have
access to lead free water Pakistan where
they like the the water levels are
lowering because of the the extraction
that they're doing and they're
essentially just pissing off everyone
and for some examples the company in
Southern California bottles 30 million
gallons each years that they pay the
u.s. Forest Service for that privilege
$524 wait what yeah
five hundred $24 for the rights to
bottle the water in Southern California
that's what they pay the u.s. Forest
Service this from a corporation yeah it
like in near Flint they pay $200 a year
and there's a great quote I didn't write
it down actually no I did write it down
maybe I didn't there's a great quote
from somebody who Manolis says you know
we're not pumping the water out or
anything it just flows into our pipes
it's not our fault that it's getting
into our pipes and we're bottling it
so anyway people have turned to area
from area 51 to nestle which I would say
is a wholesome thing to do company pull
up that we've got a few memes Nestle
said this is an image what is this from
I don't know it looks like it's
something from don't hug me I'm scared
no it's don't hug me I'm scared it's a
it's a character kind of given a side
eye and looking very nervous and it says
Nestle seeing reddit slowly turn from
area 51 to them next one chair do you
want describe so this is a disgruntled
fan who is throwing a chair at a NBA
mascot I wish I could see which mascot
it was but it's basically a disgruntled
fan after having defeated in area 51
mascot is now turning his attention
toward Nestle headquarters and is about
to smash him with a chair so it's me is
the guy throwing the chair the chair is
alien gun I got from area 51 and then
the mascot isn't Nestle headquarters
it's just those two right oh this is
another one so this what's it mr. crabby
something crabby thing I don't watch
Spongebob I'm sorry everyone
I don't either I can't help it it's the
guy who runs the burger place is evil
and it says Nestle Oh room says what
inspired you to steal water from
Pakistan and forced them to buy only
from you and then he responds money
there you go
you know I don't have a ton of yeah I
don't really have to this is the
authentic remedy to the ironic area 51
yeah it's either breaking through the
nihilism maybe this meta modernism I
don't understand but I'm glad it's a
meme yeah but do you think that either
one so first of all no one's gonna show
up at area 51 or I would argue that
probably more people are gonna show up
at area 51 that are gonna show up on the
doorstep of Nestle HQ which I think
makes it more nihilistic yeah but I
think sometimes Nestle has been doing
this for years and years and years and I
think the more it gets ingrained in
people's consciousness that they're
horrible the better
I don't you you and I Alec when I were
just before this we're talking about hey
we should do a podcast segment called
whatever happened to that
yeah about all these horrible things
that are just back in the zeitgeist or
like
for example like the war in Syria
whatever happened to that is that still
going on or I just have no idea it
started because I said whatever happened
to the Patriots that still happening did
they renew that did that get de Beckett
shit-canned I don't know are we still
living under that dystopia point is this
Nestle outrage even if it's been
happening for a while I don't think
anything's gonna happen we're gonna be
back here in two months saying hey
remember when reddit was mad at Nestle
whatever happened nothing yeah there is
one last comment that I didn't bring up
which is so the CEO of Nestle at one
point was asked about water as a human
right which by the way according to the
UN it is and he said that seems extreme
which people and since then speaking of
apologies he said that's not what I
meant that was taken out of context it
was a hundred cent not take context and
then went on the spiel about how potable
water for sustenance is a human right
but not like for your swimming pool
which I nobody would disagree with that
but that's not what he said the first
time that's why to me memes are just
more about despair than actually action
maybe sometimes Twitter leads to like
remember the Arab Spring true there
means there was Twitter I'm sure there
was memes yeah I don't really know a lot
about the Arab Spring but sounds like a
good point to make all right I got
nothing more than that you want to talk
about little na sex yeah lil na sex I'm
weirdly obsessed with so as you
mentioned yesterday he released his
area51 theme music video for the old
town can you tell us little now sex is a
new rapper on the scene right yeah I saw
he's technically a SoundCloud rapper he
uploaded this old town road to
SoundCloud and is now signed to deal
with I believe Columbia is ostensibly
making millions of dollars I'm sure he
is it's also he was I think sleeping on
someone's couch really rags-to-riches
overnight story and I think everyone's
pretty happy for him sometimes you can
get mad at the way people arbitrarily
get rich but I think
everyone's just happy for him so he so
this remix is with young thug and Mason
Ramsey who for anyone who doesn't know
is the Walmart yelling kid
my girlfriend's obsessed with him I
don't know why we already played the
music video but it's very meme Laden
they they they they charge area 51
I believe young thug is on a snake
everyone else is on a horse
the soldiers pissed themselves and then
aliens give them all the cool technology
I think little nah Saxon generals
interesting for two reasons one is I
think he's the quinces quintessential
postmodern artist or rapper whatever you
want to say why yeah so if you think
about post-modernism it is often about
scrambling or deconstructing narratives
genres symbols often times it can
involve off pastiche which is kind of
omage to a lot of different things I
often associate the word Claus with it
so even the song Old Town Road some of
you may know this already it samples
from a very obscure Nine Inch Nails song
called 34 ghost 4 which is not one of
their earlier albums one of it might be
kind of old at this point but it's
definitely one of their later albums
when Trent Reznor started being much
more experimental that is the sort of
guitar twang you hear so and also
illness axe is from Atlanta is not was
never exposed to cowboy culture in fact
when he's writing the song he had to
google cowboy words so you've got this
industrial what are they called nice
nails is like industrial electronic
music or at least originally mixed with
a kid from Atlanta who's a rapper mixed
with cowboy lingo that he had to Google
also the original music video is all
about he's out of place in the West and
then transports into modern-day LA where
he's doing hokey cowboy stuff and then
the modern urban youth are doing all
their cool dances and he's also out of
place there so it's about these like
kind of mixing of genres cultures etc
and even its status as it was taken off
the the country billboards because it
wasn't country enough and then Billy Ray
Cyrus joined and then it was country
enough so it is just kind of scrambling
all these different codes genres
etcetera
and sorry let me just check my notes
real quick and he's also gay right yeah
he came out during during Pride Month I
wouldn't say that's necessarily
postmodern but well but there is a sense
that even still there are a couple gay
rappers but in general rap is still
pretty hyper masculine yeah and very
hetero sex yeah yeah you could make that
even young thug who apparently doesn't
like sex even though he has like seven
kids he raps about you know how many
women he sleeps with yeah I guess maybe
he doesn't because he doesn't like sex
but point is even the fact that he's
openly gay is in a sense scrambling the
common narrative of rap yeah and so
there's that and even the young thug
verse in the new remix is about how he
likes sleeping with women and even just
so another part is Billy Ray Cyrus roads
verse in 15 minutes that's not
postmodern it's funny but it's all about
so you have low no sex in the song as
like country representing country and
then Billy Ray Cyrus's verse is all
about driving in fancy Maseratis etc etc
you might not be a Maserati but
essentially the bougie life so I think
it's really interesting and his other
song is a panini samples the Nirvana
melody there's just there's a lot of
weird intertextual stuff going on and I
think it's real interesting but my
second point well I don't know if you
have anything to say about that but I
have a second no it is interesting I
mean obviously I don't think he's
deliberately doing this on kids well
well I think that I don't think he's at
reading postmodern theory but I think
yeah but the aesthetic that he grew up
with was a lot of sampling is a lot of
just confusing different things yeah he
he's basically is living the kind of
postmodern trajectory of media right and
of course the means right I mean he's
probably was very in on internet culture
even before he became an essential part
of internet culture right the second
thing I'd say unless you have something
to add sir be no so I think he's also
interesting he keeps remix in the same
song over and over again
can we actually show
the first wheat I have is ax this is his
official Twitter I act like I'm okay
but deep down inside I want to release
another Old Town Road remix so for
anyone who doesn't know there is way too
many there's so the song was a released
that was remixed with Billy Ray Cyrus
which got on the country charts
then Diplo D did a remix and then more
recently young the remix with the area
51
young thug and Mason Ramsay it's only
three yeah four total yeah but I feel
like it's such it and each one is just
blowing up so the reason so I think his
constant remixes is the final form of
the culture industry I'll get into what
that means but he doesn't ironically so
I'm pretty okay with it
so this guy Theodor Adorno I don't know
if you ever heard of him you wrote a
book Theodor Adorno wrote a book with
Max Horkheimer and one of the chapters
is about this thing called the culture
industry where he said he's talking
about Hollywood he's talking about jazz
he really hates jazz don't agree with
him on that but whatever he said the
culture industry is an endless
repetition of the same commodities we
get an ostensibly wide range of products
say cars but it's all from the same
limited menu of interchangeable options
it's like getting a Model T but you can
get in red blue you can get in six
different colors or you could get it
with leather fabric seats you're still
getting the same car but you have sort
of the illusion of choice so adorned or
thought this applied to movies and music
as well where you have the constant
rehashing of very similar movie plot
lines which is I'm sure something you're
very familiar with charit is a film nerd
or the rehashing of jazz standards over
and over again
now Fedora was kind of crotchety and I
hated all pop culture which is not true
of me but weirdly little non-sex by just
weari releasing the same song with the
most tiniest amount of changes just a
verse in an inconsequential verse from
young thug I think is the culmination of
this yeah but this isn't anything new
when it comes to rap music
I mean UGK which was big in the 90s
they're big one of their big songs
international players anthem
there's like six or seven remixes of
that and because a lot of I'm not a rap
expert by any means but it's all about
collabs it's all about yeah you know
some so and so's got a hit
I've got a label that has all these
other rappers under it and I'm trying to
build their careers so that we can all
come up together and then you end up
taking this hit song turning in like six
different ones and then you know we all
come up together I mean that happens all
the time
yeah and I think there's a different
collaboration it's fine right if you
know when Nicki Minaj has a verse on
monster with Kanye West like it's really
good and she I think adds something to
that and I like this song and I'm not
afraid maybe it's a guilty pleasure but
I feel like these verses don't really
add anything as evidenced by the fact
that Billy Ray Cyrus did his in 15
minutes but actually it shows but that's
also pretty common I mean often times
when it's rappers it's not that they
come in with something prepared
oftentimes it's hey come in the studio
we're gonna get real [ __ ] up and
you're just gonna keep riffing on stuff
until we get something that we like yeah
and maybe it's just the so yes it exists
in rap maybe it's just the scale of it
and actually can you show that second
tweet Mitch thank you this I think is
where we're heading so this is a tweet
from at make it Ryan underscore James
Ray the year is 2090 every song in the
Billboard Top 100 hour old town a little
na sax is President every American has
been required to send in a one-minute
freestyle to add to his upcoming old
town road country single area 51 has
been overrun you have a pet alien life
is good that's pretty good yeah and if
anything if this is maybe maybe rap is
just the most advanced form of
capitalism and music it is it is it's I
mean because they're all trying to yeah
I mean the mood the music is about
making money and so the efforts to make
money are equally shameless and people
including myself will follow along in
their efforts to make money so yeah I
don't listen to rap music so I'm
not very educated in this area but from
my experience rap music doesn't rely
heavily on like those synthesizers that
change one's voice so that's why I
appreciate auto-tune yeah Travis Scott
is all that he's huge but but sorry go
on
so the reason why I appreciated rap
music is that I felt that it was more
authentic like you're you're just that's
your voice which I appreciate a lot and
also I think there is quite a bit of
room for creativity and innovation and
and this person lil nas ex so down with
the kids these days so I think I like
that he has collaborated across genres
to create music and I I think there
aren't very many artists that do that at
least from my experience so I think it's
good I think it's brave I mean it's
definitely risky so good for him yeah
and the other thing I'll say is the
second tweet I said about its 29d and
every lil das acts retweeted that which
is again I'm okay with all of it for
whatever reason I think cuz he doesn't
self-aware Lee but also to my point
about how it's the culmination of the
culture industry it is the
longest-running
billboard number-one single ever that's
amazing yeah I don't know if I agree
with you on when people are self-aware
that they're doing something maybe a
little cheap if that makes it better
sometimes I think it makes it worse I'm
honestly not entirely sold whether it
makes it better or worse but I won't
defend it you're totally right sometimes
it's terrible but for whatever reason in
this exact instance of all no sex
because it's like the jewel people it's
like we know that we're selling to kids
and we know we're going to apologize for
it but as long as we know that it's okay
they just need to ironically market to
kids are that idea jewel I'm sure
they're already working on it do you
want to do this last one and then go
into the mailbag yeah what how are we
doing on time
I feel like we should we go straight to
the mailbag is that okay sir B that's
like I'll bring this in next week
yeah next we cool eyes if you want to
send us emails culture binge at
wisecrack Co one's gonna
CEO not calm because some rich guy owns
that and won't give it to us and if you
want to send us a voicemail we've
actually got a voicemail that we're
gonna play it's 2 1 3 [ __ ] to one elf
got oh seven two one three five three
four eight eight zero seven two one elf
gut oh seven or elf hut oh seven same
number Ryan says Hut's sound better than
guts which I get oh my god
yeah yeah the hell rhyme yeah but you
want to go party at the elf hut I mean
but the elf gut this is nasty
Ryan's also the grotius person I know
and I mean that with all the lovin I
[Laughter]
hate wisecrack this one's for culture
binge this last episode you guys talked
about reality TBD
which I thought was great and he spent a
lot of time talking about reality TV as
a form of entertainment where you could
just turn off and you guys didn't spend
a whole lot of time comparing it to
other forms of entertainment that you
can just turn off for like YouTube
videos of people narrowly avoiding
injuries or people getting owned in
arguments I think people seek out
arguments that are not challenging to
them that confirm their biases ease as a
way of also avoiding being challenged
and I wonder if you guys to comment on
that additionally I don't think you guys
talked about how reality television
might be a progression in how our
culture interacts with narrative if we
if we tell stories that we identify with
and that's the reason why we enjoy them
then it's only natural that eventually
we would want to see those same types of
stories and archetypes
but authentic versions of them and
reality TV might just be the extra
element of authentic to the stories that
we've been telling forever anyway
love the show wisecrack is awesome Alex
podcast order of things is awesome and I
know that's also a theory start sharing
some of her other sources of content
with us too mundane it's going to be
much bye
so in terms of other first of all thank
you anonymous for that voicemail that
was really great as far as the comparing
it to other forms of entertainment that
are mindless yeah I mean I who doesn't
love a good fail video but I would say
that the when we're talking about kind
of quote unquote ruining reality I think
the main point was on the narrative
ization which is kind of his second
point but I don't know I mean I don't
think a lot of those fail videos are
staged are they either way I don't think
anyone says like oh man I wish that was
me I wish I liked myself on fire I mean
for nihilist Millennials definitely they
want to be that person yeah I'm just
kidding but I totally agree on his point
about how reality TV is perhaps just a
more authentic way to experience the
same catharsis that you would with the
normal narrative I think it's pretty
interesting no I and I think that's
totally true and I think the thing I
think the quest for authenticity as it
exists in advertising as it is a
narrative gets really weird especially
when you look at the Rita's branding
campaign yeah obviously there would
never be any kind of reality TV that's I
mean there's always gonna be the fantasy
escapism which is never gonna work with
reality I mean I guess you could have
like reality TV LARPing but I don't
think that would be very appealing but
yeah reality TV is certainly tapping
into something essential about our
current condition whether it's with
entertainment whether it is with
narrative whether it's just in zoning
out and so I think his insights are
pretty interesting yeah okay I've got
some mail let's just a mail before I get
in the mail for all the people who are
doing it on our live stream I have your
names if I miss any I'm deeply sorry I
haven't been checking my phone the whole
time because I've been talking to my
friends here my virtual friends real
friends he's never met surbhi we were
very close to each other and I was too
busy watching tweens dance to see if
they would stop dancing when no one was
watching them
creepy dude I'm sorry
anyway thank you to damiana Smith do -
bye - I think donate a bunch of times
chibi arcade coffin and Bob Lin yours
didn't have any questions they wanted to
say I've since lost them because it goes
I'm sorry guys thank you thank you
all right into the actual mailbag here's
an email from Ryan longtime consumer
first-time commenter yada yada quick
note about Libra which we talked about a
few weeks ago now that's the Facebook
cryptocurrency
I loathe Facebook but I see a benefit in
Libra I live and work in kurtik sorry
God
thank you curiously and nearly a third
of this country's GDP is dependent on
remittances from labor migrants that is
when people work abroad and send money
home people here either lose huge sums
of money sending money home via Western
Union or take a chance and in cash home
with somebody with whatsapp being the
default messaging app for everyone here
the ability to send money home safely
with lower rates using an app people use
anyway
Libra could be a game-changer here thank
you for doing your thing Ryan I loved
this email actually I've been loving a
lot of the emails of it have been coming
through people are so interesting and
they share so much knowledge with us but
this email in particular I thought was
super interesting because it provides a
different perspective where I never I
never would have thought that there
would be an actual use come impactful
use case yeah where we can change
somebody's life and help a culture and
help a people so that was really
interesting thank you for sharing yeah I
think it's a really interesting
perspective and I think you feel this
way too because you also with Facebook
it seems like a deal with the devil it
is a real problem that they that they
are seriously addressing but they are
also a horrible horrible company and
somebody else do this that's yeah yeah
can't somebody else I wish somebody else
would do it
you can do it and like we can call it
crack or some oh yeah crackling back
coin yeah yeah if any developers are out
there want to develop this
cryptocurrency for free we will push on
the podcast don't do that the next email
is from Alex
hey waz crack in a recent culture binge
episode you talked about personality
test I actually work for one of the
companies that administers such chests
as a software developer I can tell you
first hand that myers-briggs is the bane
of our existence it's incredibly out of
date and no psychologist should use it
but unfortunately it's still very
well-known part of the problem is that
algorithms that generate your results
are closely guarded secrets of the
industry
I just want to flag that me Alex to talk
about I'd love to share our algorithms
with you to demonstrate how much better
they are the myers-briggs but I
concludes my job understandable the
other part is interpreting the results
as part of what we sell sounds like the
people on the podcast had experienced
what happens when someone tries to apply
the results of a personality test
without the help of a psychologist I so
yes I I mean my whole issue comes down
to as this person pointed down to even
if it's not Myers Brigg even it's
supposedly a science behind it because
it's proprietary it is impossible for
consumers to separate pseudoscience from
real science because science as a
process involves things like peer review
and I don't know what that looks like in
a proprietary measuring service
especially when if you're doing a like
personality let's say you're doing
personality test to determine if someone
gets parole or gets a job or gets fired
or gets a promotion I am highly
suspicious although I have seen I mean I
don't even know if they're called
personality test but psychologists do
administer tests all the time to say you
know the kind of tests that determine if
your child has a learning disability or
other things like that and I think we
got another email that I'm not gonna
read but I think just the idea to give
you insight in the same way
psychologists might tell you hey I
noticed that you have a tendency to over
inflate like the that people hate you
and like knowing that about yourself as
a helpful thing so in that sense I'm
kind of okay with them barry's I think
it's interesting as a single date point
and doing self examination or
understanding who you are I actually
this email I I think I may have taken
that not the exact same personality test
that Alex is
company does but the personality test
that I took in business school was a 360
degree feedback and it went into various
layers of my personality so I agreed
with a lot of it but some of it I
disagreed with but I thought that it was
still an interesting perspective and
like one one data point in the totality
of my personality in my life yeah to
think one I remember when Jacob who runs
the company with me made me went back
when I was his intern he made me take a
myers-briggs test and the reason was
he's like because everybody's useful at
a company he's got to figure out where
they fit and I was like no some people
are utterly useless and that's how I
know that this test is [ __ ] that's
not true
but I I mean not in an existential sense
but in you know our system some people
are useless
tragically yeah not everyone whatever
yeah anyway the second thing I want to
ask you guys is you guys ever have to
take a this is like pre myers-briggs a
test in like middle school to determine
what job you'd be good for I don't
remember but I what did you what did
yours come up with Serbia anyway think
something it was like I forgot what it
was exactly like the like what the name
of it was but that the professions were
leader actress manager somebody in
television like it was something that
was like that would involve like a lot
of like public speaking or persuasion
and things like that lawyer was one of
them mm-hmm not lying I literally got
chimney-sweep that's not even a real job
I know I don't know you have chimneys in
Texas no no I had a chimney in Texas I
don't think it needed someone to come
sweep it because there's we don't need
the fire to actually keep it warm yeah I
don't remember if I took one but I can
imagine whatever it said it did not say
writing videos on YouTube that would be
crazy if it did maybe that's in the new
ones now the update is you should be
answer that that's what it is you all
usually come up with mukbang for sure
yeah if you love attention
you just get influenced or if you'll
have attention and eating mukbang all
right we got one more yeah
sorry let me just decide which one we
could do two more whatever all right
let's do Andreas
hello wisecrack big fan chant occult
urban has been a great addition to the
list of shows you've recently talked a
lot about college education finding a
job as millennial and [ __ ] jobs I
feel like one of the biggest
developments we've seen in the past 20
years is that it feels like you need to
have an education to have a job I'm from
Denmark and even though education is
free the school bench still isn't for
everyone my grandparents generation have
the ability to take a free education and
find a job but also the opportunity to
just work themselves up within an
industry it seems like nowadays you have
to have an education even for jobs that
before would just require work
experience professions that have
traditionally been seen as a
craftsmanship have become increasingly
more theoretical in their education and
have become increasingly hard to work
with if you don't have the proper
education for it what do you think
what do you what do you think this has
changed is it the same in the u.s. best
regards andreas I mean just to south yes
it's a hundred century in the u.s. you
need a college degree for any dumb for
any job [ __ ] or otherwise [ __ ] or
otherwise you know even answering the
phones at a company college degree I
think I agree I think most entry-level
roles require college degrees I don't
know why that is I thought about it I I
don't know like when that shift occurred
like did it was it a result of more
people entering the workforce there was
a way to like thin things out or yeah I
think it's completely superficial like
that I think it's more people entering
the workforce and I think because the
the rapid expansion of college education
now almost everyone has a college degree
or lots of much more people do that
it's like yeah it's become a weird
cultural norm and that we devalue people
who don't
I think incorrectly and also probably a
weird way to just like stereotype people
to say oh you don't have a college
degree you must be a dumb-dumb which is
again not true but yeah even I mean I
have a friend who I went to school with
he did the same major I did we talked
about political philosophy all day and
after years of working service jobs he
is going to get an apprenticeship in
plumbing plumbing or elevator repair wow
that's incredible that's a good job no
that's a great job and to be honest
he'll probably make way more money than
I did a lot of money yeah but the fact
that I'm sure he's stolen debt the fact
that he's probably almost 30 now I you
know the fact that it took him that long
and that's not a criticism of him I'm
just saying I think it happens a lot of
times where people either oh I have a
degree in history but I'm gonna get an
entry-level job marketing and marketing
is my career history has nothing to do
with that or I'm gonna go to school but
then go back to school for something
like nursing or to a crafts school or
something like that yeah that's why I
say when people email saying you guys
make me one study philosophy I would I
would say study plumbing first and then
study minor minor and philosophy major
in plumbing that's not a real major
whatever plumber is an elevator
repairman people make so much money I
once met somebody who was taking the
exam for elevator repair and it was
logic-based and it was incredible and I
had no idea so much went into it but
apparently she was going to make a [ __ ]
ton of money so if anybody's out there
who doesn't want to work an office job
or work in like a traditional role I
highly suggest you go into plumbing or
elevator repair or something like that
like a trade in that realm because
that's where all the money's that
another one is air conditioning repair
okay if you go to if you study air
conditioning repair and then move to
Houston Texas or somewhere where it's
really hot we're gonna make Bank thank
ya it's similar I mean nursing is a big
one but I don't know if they make well I
think a lot and get underpaid
I know for a lot worse nursing is rough
that's a tough job oh yeah nursing
support nursing is a whole culture of
hazing that people don't really talk
about really yeah
if you're a nurse you're working
horrible hours you know I've I've known
nurses that tell me that the the nurses
with seniority because there's just been
this culture of hazing for so long they
totally abuse you they're really really
mean they make you work horrible hours
just the actual work that you're doing
can often be soul-crushing
right it is a rough grind the other
thing I was gonna say I don't think they
make as much bang but I also know people
go to college and then go back to be
like physician's assistant which is a
lot less schooling but I think I pay
what the physicians or something like
that I think you can make a living I
don't think you can make Bank like an
elevator repairman but I think you can
make depending on your specialty I think
you can make about 130,000 Wow Wow all
right you want to do last one yeah this
one is about a key guy this is an email
from damn he says hey wisecrack this is
Dan from Miami I'm watching culture
binge number seven right now listening
to surbhi talk about icky guy and I
thought it would add some additional
insight into Okinawan culture I'm not an
expert in Okinawan culture by any means
but I do have an undergraduate degree in
exercise physiology and master's degree
in nutrition super cool we learned about
the Okinawans in both of those programs
and some additional theories about their
long lifespans
iki guy was one of the things we learned
about however the Okinawans also barely
eat any meat at all and when they do it
is usually fish which of course has a
lot of healthy omega-3 unsaturated fats
that are really good for your car sorry
cardiovascular health they rarely if
ever consume meat from land animals like
beef from pork which are highly higher
in sorry which are higher in unhealthy
saturated fats the Okinawans are also
more active than Westerners and continue
to be active late in life sir we
mentioned a man who teaches martial arts
when he's over 100 years old this is not
uncommon for their culture finally and
most interestingly their culture
encourages people not to overeat in fact
they usually only until they are about
75 to 80% full all these things together
I exercise and I are a perfect storm for
health it is also worth knowing that
oaken Allen's have the longest lifespans
in the world these numbers are starting
to slowly normalize this is likely
because of Western culture is beginning
to seep into the world things like fast
food chains are beginning to pop up and
their lifespans decreasing as a result
we just got to ruin everything there's a
similar thing about Western diets
ruining the world so if anyone's heard
about like the microbiome is kind of the
ecosystem in your gut it changes your
mental health it changes how you digest
food lots of different things that
they're slowly learning in science but
they did a study of people who migrated
to America and studying their microbiome
I think a year after or maybe six months
after essentially the the conclusion of
the study is that after six months or
year people's microbiome are completely
ruined by the American diet they're just
have like all the same bacteria and all
the same problems with cardiovascular
diseases etc etc but thank you for this
email Dan I also have the idea of eating
I don't love this idea I hate this idea
but I'm glad somebody does like eating
to 75 to 80% full that's someone who
created a scale to measure their hunger
or fullness at all times of the day to
communicate with my partner
I appreciate that there is a percentage
that other people are putting to it yeah
I eat to max capacity me too it's only
because I mean food I think is my drug
of choice yeah if that if I can get
wasted or eat I'm gonna eat yeah I
stress eat a lot yeah and the other
things that I have food allergies so
when there is something that I can eat
especially when I'm traveling and I
don't know whether or not like I'll be
able to eat again I tend to eat a lot
all at once because I'll be like I may
not eat for the rest of the day like who
knows so I tend to overeat in weird
times and people are like well that's a
little weird but this is why a mukbang
career is a natural choice for me yeah
eating is the most effective silencing
of that anxiety voice in the back of
your head for some reason when I'm
eating it just isn't there I'm too
focused on the sensation of food so the
more you eat the last nihilist means
you'll make that's the thing about meals
they only last what thirty minutes as a
whole
here here's another donation from from
dude abides what food will sir be
indulge in her mukbang vids Oh french
fries okay oh I love french fries that
is something that I could eat all day
everyday like a ton of french fries how
do you feel about sweet potato fries no
what about french fries with Creole
seasoning I don't know what Creole
seasoning is it's not Old Bay seasoning
but to me it's there somewhere in my
head a Cajun
Yallah Cajun sorry oh yeah okay I could
do that maybe not a bunch of them but
some okay I'll keep that in mind
I might just show up at your door one
day sir be with a camera hooked up to
YouTube live and a bunch of friends that
would be like a dream come true I would
be like oh this is way better than Ed
McMahon shoot my door people should stop
swatting people but instead should
french fry people we're just someone
shows up at your door while you're live
streaming with thousands of french fries
right I think that would make the world
a better place yeah all right guys we're
gonna wrap it up thanks so much for
listening in terms of the time that
we're live-streaming we're doing it now
earlier surbhi has a real job that she's
gracious enough to work around her
schedule so we announced in our video
that is gonna be Wednesdays at 12:30
Pacific that might have to change so
stay tuned and we will hopefully get it
as a will hopefully get it to a regular
time every week but one last call please
subscribe to this podcast on Apple
podcast Google podcast stitcher please
leave us a review the more reviews we
get asking surbhi to do mukbang the more
likely it is that she's gonna do it
maybe we should actually set like if we
get like 500 reviews surbhi well I don't
even tell her because when she drops
dead of a heart attack I'll do one in
one video one video one video my debut
and my swan song yes
okay with french fries french fries okay
how many I don't know we're gonna have
to like come up with the parameters of
this like I don't know like what is a
good amount I don't know what my thing
people eat and
do your research maybe like seven order
six orders of in and out for Christ I
don't think that's not ten tens a good
number
that's okay okay alright thanks for
listening
Apple podcast Google podcast leaders to
review patreon.com slash wisecrack
anything you guys do to help us out much
appreciated we will see you guys next
week
thanks to Alec thanks to Sir B and until
next time peace
[Music]